a few question about the classical World
Championship that you're obviously not
playing I guess it's you know it's yeah
I'm I'm not playing the candidates don't
worry about that I would say the main
reason that I I'm not playing the
classical World Championship is that I
don't enjoy it yeah it's as simple as
that I think under the current format
with the time control that there is it's
extremely unlikely that I will compete
in the classical World
Championship I've had a great well two
years now uh since I played the last
World
Championship yeah I really don't really
don't miss it I really like the life
that I have now both playing from home
but also traveling playing tournaments
and um yeah I simply simply don't need
it what would it have to look like what
would the format need to be for you to
eat consider going
back I think if you reduced time
controls made it more games that would
be a very good start